>>> MY PILLOW GUY MIKE LINDELL
SAID THE FBI SERVED HIM WITH A
GRAND JURY SUBPOENA FOR THE
CONTENTS OF HIS PHONE IN
CONNECTION WITH A COLORADO
ELECTION SECURITY BREACH.
>> CARS PULLED UP IN FRONT OF
US, TO THE SIDE OF US AND BEHIND
US.
I SAID, THOSE ARE EITHER BAD
GUYS OR THE FBI.
WELL, IT TURNS OUT THEY WERE THE
FBI.
I SAID, CAN YOU GET ME TO THE
JANUARY 6th CORRUPTION?
I SAID, I VOLUNTEERED TO GO
THERE.
THEY SAID, MIKE, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT COLORADO.
HE GOES, WE'RE TAKING YOUR CELL
PHONE.
WE HAVE A WARRANT FOR YOUR CELL
I GO, NO.
I SAID, MY WHOLE COMPANY, I RUN
FIVE COMPANIES OFF THAT.
I DON'T HAVE A COMPUTER.
MY HEARING AIDS RUN OFF THIS.
EVERYTHING RUNS OFF MY PHONE.
I SAID -- AND THEN I SAID, IF I
DON'T GIVE IT TO YOU WILL YOU
ARREST ME THEN?
>> ALL RIGHT.
WITH ME NOW IS STATE ATTORNEY
FOR PALM BEACH COUNTY, FLORIDA,
DAVID AARONBURG.
ALL RIGHT, COUNSELOR.
MIKE LINDELL HAD HIS PHONE IN
COLORADO.
>> HE WAS PICKED UP AT A HARDY'S
DRIVE THROUGH.
IT PROVIDES FURTHER EVIDENCE
FAST FOOD MAY NOT BE GOOD FOR
YOU.
TO GET A SEARCH WARRANT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE PROBABLE CAUSE THAT A
CRIME OCCURRED AND EVIDENCE OF
THE CRIME IS ON THE PHONE.
THIS INVOLVES HIM BEING IN
CAHOOTS AND A QANON WORKER.
>> THE TIMING OF THIS, WHAT DO
YOU MAKE OF?
>> IT ALL CAME 60 DAYS BEFORE
THE MID-TERM ELECTION.
THAT'S WHEN THEY TURN DOWN THE
VOLUME OF THE INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
SEEN AS BEING POLITICAL.
THERE'S A REASON YOU HAD THE
SUBPOENA BLITZ CREEK.
>> BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO GET IT
ALL IN BEFORE 60 DAYS.
I'LL GET TO THAT.
I THINK PEOPLE OFTEN WONDER THIS
WHEN A PHONE IS TAKEN BY THE
FBI.
WHATEVER HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th
AND IT IS NOW.
WOULDN'T MIKE LINDELL IF HE KNEW
HE WAS UNDER THE SPOTLIGHT START
DELETING STUFF MONTHS AGO?
>> YES, BUT THEY'VE GOT REALLY
GOOD COMPUTER EXPERTS AND THEY
CAN GET THE DELAY TBACK.
THERE'S A LOT OF BAD STUFF THAT
COULD BE FOUND ON SOMEONE'S
PHONE.
ONCE THE FBI GETS IT, IT COULD
BE A FREE-FOR-ALL.
MIKE LYNN ZELL IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE HERE.
MY ADVICE TO HIM WOULD BE TO
USE SOME MY PILLOW MONEY TO HIRE
A GOOD CRIMINAL DEFENSE LAWYER.
>> THE DOZENS AND DOZENS WHO
HAVE GONE OUT AS PART OF THE 6th
HEARING.
THE SUBPOENAS ARE PRETTY BROAD.
THERE ARE A COUPLE DIFFERENT
WAYS OF LOOKING AT THAT.
WHO DO YOU SEE?
>> IT IS PRETTY BROAD.
FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME AND THE
FINANCIAL SCHEME WHEN IT COMES
TO SAVE AMERICA PAC.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS IN HERE, I
WILL LEGITIMATE BODIES.
IF YOU CAN CHARGE ON THAT, YOU
CAN HAVE OBSTRUCTION AS AN ISSUE
AND THE WE BUILD THE WALL
CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S SOMETHING PROSECUTORS SAL
LIVE VAT OVER.
PEOPLE LIE BUT PAPERS DON'T.
>> THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH ISSUE,
THAT SEEMS TO BE A FINITE AREA.
JANUARY 6th, YES, IT MEANS DOJ
IS TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY,
PURSUING A LOT OF AVENUES, BUT
THEY MAY NOT BE FOCUSED ON
ANYTHING.
MAYBE NOT CLOSE TOSS KIND OF
EMPD DETERRENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
HE HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE BETWEEN
THEM.
TO CHARGE TRUMP RELATED TO
JANUARY 6th, YOU NEED TO TIE
HIM.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN THE
DOCUMENT MATTER WHEN HE'S TIED
DIRECTLY TO THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
HIS PASSPORTS, ALL OF HIS
PERSONAL ITEMS ARE FOUND
INTERMINGLED WITH THAT.
ON ONE END YOU HAVE THE JANUARY
6th INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT INVOLVING THE
ATTEMPTED OVERTHROW OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IT'S HARD TO TY TRUMP DIRECTLY
TO THAT AS WELL.
YOU CAN TIE TRUMP TO IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.